>>> SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS IS
PUBLICLY SLAMMING JOE BIDEN
AFTER THE WEST VIRGINIA -- JOE
MANCHIN AFTER HE TORPEDOED
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S CLIMATE AND
TAX AGENDA.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> PEOPLE LIKE MANCHIN, SINEMA
TO A LESSER DEGREE, WHO ARE
INTENTIONALLY SABOTAGING THE
PRESIDENT'S AGENDA, WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANTI, WHAT A
MAJORITY OF THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS WANT.
WE CONTINUED TO TALK TO MANCHIN
LIKE HE WAS SERIOUS.
HE WAS NOT.
>> OVER AT THE WHITE HOUSE, THE
RHETORIC IS NOTICEABLY LESS
FIERY.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO GET INTO THE
TOS AND FROS BACK AND FORTH.
THE PRESIDENT FOR SOME TIME HAS
BEEN LAYING OUT WHAT WE NEED TO
DO ON CLEAN ENERGY.
IF CONGRESS AND THE SENATE IS
NOT GOING TO ACT ON THAT FRONT,
HE IS GOING TO TAKE THE POWERS
THAT HE HAS WITH EXECUTIVE
AUTHORITY AND TAKE STEPS ON THAT
FRONT.
>> OUR PANEL IS BACK TO DISCUSS
THIS.
SO, MANU, OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE ARE
FURIOUS.
ALTHOUGH SOME PEOPLE WOULD BE
LIKE, WELL, BERNIE SANDERS IS
NOT A DEMOCRAT BUT HE'S SPEAKING
FOR THE PROGRESSIVE WING OF THE
PARTY RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH.
LOOK, HE MAY NOT LIKE IT, BUT
BERNIE SANDERS HAS TO DEAL WITH
THE REALITY THAT THEY ARE IN A
50-50 SENATE AND TRYING TO PASS
JOE BIDEN'S AGENDA THROUGH A
BUDGET PROCESS THAT REQUIRES
THEM TO DO IT ALONG STRAIGHT
PARTY LINES.
THEY CAN DO IT ALONG STRAIGHT
PARTY LINES WHICH IS WHAT THEY
ARE TRYING TO DO.
THEY NEED MANCHIN'S SUPPORT AND
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE BEEN
FRUSTRATED THE LAST YEAR TRYING
TO GET A DEAL.
REMEMBER WHERE THEY STARRED.
THEY STARTED TALKING ABOUT A
$3.5 TRILLION EXPANSION OF THE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET.
MANCHIN WAS OPEN TO IT, TALKING
ABOUT IT, HE SUGGESTED $1.5
TRILLION.
NOW THEY'RE NOT ANYWHERE CLOSE
TO THAT.
BUT THERE IS -- COULD BE SOME
SIGNIFICANT POLICY CHANGES.
HE IS OPEN TO ALLOWING MEDICARE
TO NEGOTIATE THE PRICE OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
HE'S ALSO WILLING TO EXTEND
EXPIRING SUBSIDIES UNDER THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
SO THERE COULD BE SOME POLICY
PROVISIONS THAT GET INTO LAW,
BUT THAT'S STILL NOT ENOUGH FOR
WHAT THE LEFT WANTS.
>> THAT IS OF THE THINGS THAT
THEY STARTED WITH, THEY ARE DOWN
TO TWO OF THE ITEMS.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS, AS YOU HEARD
THERE, NOT REALLY TAKING THIS AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SLAM MANCHIN,
BECAUSE THEY THINK THAT THEY
NEED TO GET TO A DEAL WITH HIM.
POLITICO WROITES THIS.
UNLIKE SANDERS, SCHUMER AND THE
WHITE HOUSE ARE NOT ATTACKING
MAN
MANCHIN.
THEY WANT TO MOVE PAST HIM AND
EMPHASIZE THE VICTORY ACHIEVED
RATHER THAN WHAT WAS LOST.
A RECONCILIATION BILL THAT
LOWERS PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES
AND SUBSIDIES TO MILLIONS WHO
RELY ON THE ACA WILL BE ONE OF
THE BILLS PASSED IN A LONG TIME.
IN OTHER WORDS, TAKE THE WIN.
>> AND EXPECT TO HEAR MORE OF
THAT FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S ALLIES IN THE
COMING DAYS AND WEEKS WHERE
ESSENTIALLY THE MESSAGE IS,
LOOK, WE'RE FOCUSED ON WHAT WE
CAN GET, NOT WHAT'S ALREADY
HAPPENED BUT WHAT IS STILL
SALVAGEABLE.
BUT THE REALITY IS AS MANU JUST
SAID, THERE IS REAL FRUSTRATION.
THERE'S REAL FRUSTRATION AT JOE
MANCHIN, ALTHOUGH THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS LONG SORT OF STOPPED
READING OUT ANY ACTIVITIES,
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THE WHITE
HOUSE AND SENATOR MANCHIN.
I THINK THAT THERE IS GROWING
FRUSTRATION THAT YOU HEAR FROM
THE BASE, FROM DEMOCRATS, WHO
FEEL LIKE, WELL, WE KNOW WE HAVE
A DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WE KNOW THAT DEMOCRATS CONTROL
CONGRESS.
SO WHY ISN'T MORE GETTING DONE?
OF COURSE THE POLITICAL REALITY
IS WHAT YOU JUST POINTED OUT, IT
IS 50-50, EVENLY DIVIDED SENATE.
THEY CAN'T GET ANYTHING DONE
UNLESS JOE MANCHIN GETS BEHIND
AND EVERY MEMBER OF THE PARTY
GETS BEHIND.
>> WE ARE QUICKLY APPROACHING
THE MIDTERMS AS WELL AND THESE
FRONT-LINE DEMOCRATS ARE
SOUNDING THE ALARM.
MARK KELLY IN ARIZONA SAYS THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION NEEDS TO BE
LOOKING FOR MORE OPPORTUNITIES.
RAPHAEL WARNOCK IN GEORGIA, WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING.
ELISSA SLOTKIN SAYING WHAT WE
NEED IS A PLAN.
I AM NOT LOOKING FOR A MESSAGING
PLAN.
INFLATION IS VERY BAD AND JOE
BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATING IS BAD
AND GETTING WORSE IT SEEMS.
SO THE STAKES ARE VERY HIGH FOR
SOMETHING TO GET DONE.
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN, I MEAN HE SPENT
FOUR DECADES IN WASHINGTON
BEFORE SO HE WANTS SOMETHING
DELIVERABLE FOR HIS MEMBERS TO
GO BACK HOME WITH.
BUT M.J. MAKES A GOOD POINT.
JUST THE LEVEL OF FRUSTRATION
FROM THE BASE.
THE BASE FOR THE PREVIOUS FOUR
YEARS AND THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION SAW ALL OF THE
DELIVERABLES THAT WENT TOWARD
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BASE.
THEY WANTED THE SAME THING OUT
OF PRESIDENT BIDEN, TO KEEP HIS
PARTY IN LINE AND ON TRACK AND
UNIFIED AS WELL.
THEN WHEN MANCHIN GOES ASTRAY,
THAT ADDS TO THE FRUSTRATION
WITH BOTH HIM BUT ALSO PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S ABILITY TO UNITE HIS
PARTY.
>> WHAT IS THE DEMOCRATS'
MESSAGE RUNNING INTO THE
MIDTERMS?
THEY REALLY DON'T HAVE ONE.
THEY'RE NOW RUNNING -- THEY
RECOGNIZE FULL WELL THAT
INFLATION ALSO WILL BE THE
DOMINANT ISSUE AHEAD OF THE
MIDTERMS.
HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH THAT?
THEY ALL HAVE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
IDEAS, NONE OF THEM WHICH WILL
BECOME LAW, LIKE A GAS TAX
HOLIDAY WOULD HAVE MUCH OF AN
IMPACT ON GAS PRICES OR ANYTHING
ELSE BUT THAT IS THEIR REAL FEAR
HERE.
THE ECONOMY OF COURSE IS GOING
TO BE A BIG FACTOR HERE AND
PEOPLE ARE FEELING IT AND WILL
POTENTIALLY TAKE IT OUT AGAINST
THE PARTY IN POWER.
>> A MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
THAT DID GET DONE SEEMS TO BE IN
THE REAR-VIEW MIRROR.